Це відео протестів у Москві 3 серпня миттєво розлетілося соціальними мережами.
Його головний герой - Андрій Кургін - приїхав на мітинг на велосипеді
і потрапив під кийки поліцейських.
Саме велосипед врятував його від затримання, вважає Андрій.
З велосипедом мене незручно було нікуди засунути, повалили, відгамселили,
я від велосипеда не відчіплявся ні в яку, тому що він мені дуже дорогий,
тому що це мій транспорт основний по місту і взагалі…
Велосипедний шолом, рюкзак і сам велосипед захистили Андрія,
але синці та подряпини все ж залишилися.
На дії поліції, які він трактує як напад, Андрій поскаржився в прокуратуру.
Напад гопників був на мене, тому що поліція так не працює,
в законі про поліцію чітко прописано, як повинні діяти правоохоронці.
Тут поліції я не побачив, тут був просто напад гопників зі спини,
такий раптовий, абсолютно дурний напад.
А це відео можна було побачити не лише в соціальних мережах,
але й на федеральних телеканалах.
Там повідомили, що молода пара передала свою однорічну дитину учаснику мітингу,
щоб той скористався малюком як живим щитом.
Прокуратура вимагала позбавити подружжя батьківських прав.
Ролик, який показують по телебаченню, видно, що це монтаж.
Нарізані якісь шматки,
абсолютно неможливо визначити, це один потік знято чи не один.
Звук звідки, текст накладено, якась грізна музика…
Чоловік, якому передали дитину, - двоюрідний брат Ольги і друг Дмитра Сергій Фомін.
Молоді люди всі разом вийшли на прогулянку в центр Москви.
Батьки стверджують, що ніякої небезпеки здоров'ю і життю дитини не було.
Передати дитини родичу - у мене навіть думки не було,
що я роблю щось бодай наближене до неправильного.
Нині вирішується питання про припинення кримінальної справи щодо батьків малюка.
Фотографію Ольги Мисик надрукували багато закордонних видань.
На мітингу 27 липня 17-річна дівчина вийшла до лав ОМОНу
і зачитала їм 31-шу статтю Конституції РФ про свободу мирних зібрань.
З тих пір, з 27 липня, конституці я стала символом, і тепер я її завжди ношу при собі.
Це символ особистого протесту проти беззаконня.
Після акції дівчину затримали і відвезли у поліцейське відділення,
де склали протокол про адміністративне правопорушення.
Але ні це, ні заборони батьків не зупиняють її від участі в мітингах.
Останні мітинги - це вже справа принципу,
тому що б'ють, затримують людей, які просто йшли повз, і це просто обурливо.
Людям це не подобається, і тому вони протестують.
Це не проти фальсифікації виборів, а проти беззаконня, яке відбувається.